Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Io credo fermamente nel progresso,
tema di questo TED.
Pensate all'evoluzione,
che è il tema di cui mi occupo io,
l'evoluzione dei viventi.
Pensate che magnifica storia di progresso:
in tre miliardi e mezzo di anni,
ci ha portato dall'ameba,
a Donald Trump.
(Risate)
Se non è progresso questo, giusto?
Allora io vorrei ragionare
un po' con voi -
è progresso, naturalmente;
però, ragionare un po' con voi
sulle ambivalenze del progresso, no?
Ci credo molto,
ma insomma dobbiamo valutarlo
in tutti i suoi aspetti.
Questo signore qua è un mio collega,
bravissimo: Steven Pinker, si chiama.
Leggete i suoi libri,
sono molto ben scritti,
molto interessanti.
È uno scienziato cognitivo,
un evoluzionista anche lui,
ha scritto libri importanti
sull'evoluzione del
linguaggio, in particolare.
Però, da qualche anno a questa parte
è impegnato in una campagna culturale,
filosofica - civile, oserei dire.
Vedete il titolo di questo libro?
Dobbiamo tornare all'Illuminismo,
ai valori dell'Illuminismo.
E Dio sa quanto sia davvero importante
tornare all'idea di uno spirito critico,
dell'esercizio del dubbio.
E soprattutto, ci tiene
a ribadire Steven Pinker,
torniamo a fare riferimento
ai dati, alle evidenze,
che devono essere il punto di partenza
per ogni ragionamento.
E le evidenze che lui
racconta nei suoi libri
sono alcune come queste.
Per esempio, guardate qua
i tassi di mortalità infantile,
negli ultimi due millenni,
quanto sono crollati,
quanto sono diminuiti;
e questo è un dato oggettivo,
è un segno di progresso.
Oppure, guardate l'aspettativa di vita
come si è evoluta nel corso del tempo,
dal 1800 al 1850,
e poi fino a pochi anni fa.
Anche qui abbiamo avuto
un progresso straordinario.
E mappe di questo tipo potremmo vederle
per l'accesso all'acqua,
e a molti altri parametri fondamentali.
E questo naturalmente è vero,
non c'è alcun dubbio.
E fa molto bene Pinker
a sottolineare questo,
perché noi che nasciamo
dentro una generazione,
nativi di una generazione,
tendiamo a dare per scontato
quali sono state le conquiste
di chi ci ha preceduto,
e il fatto che si moriva in modo terribile
senza anestesia o senza antibiotici
fino a un secolo,
o a un secolo e mezzo fa:
questo è oggettivo.
Ma è sufficiente questo
per stare sicuri
che siamo dentro
una traiettoria di progresso?
Se voi andate a guardare
sempre i dati di Pinker,
ce ne sono degli altri:
per esempio noi consideriamo,
da un punto di vista evolutivo,
anche la crescita della popolazione
un segno di progresso.
Naturalmente, da un punto di vista
strettamente darwiniano lo è:
il successo popolazionale
è un segno di progresso e di successo.
Vuol dire che siamo stati più bravi
ad acquisire e a consumare le risorse,
altro valore che viene sempre considerato
tra i fattori positivi
di questo progresso.
Naturalmente, però, già lo vedete
anche da come è squilibrata
questa crescita,
potrebbe esserci qualche problema
se per esempio la Nigeria,
tra qualche anno,
avrà più di due terzi
della popolazione di tutta l'Europa,
di tutti i Paesi
dell'Unione Europea, giusto?
Dobbiamo stare attenti
a capire bene
che cosa c'è dentro questi dati.
Oppure guardate quest'altro dato,
che potremmo affiancare a questo:
è il bellissimo report di Oxfam,
che è uscito qualche mese fa,
sul tema delle diseguaglianze.
Certo, ha ragione Pinker:
stiamo progredendo e abbiamo fatto
dei passi da gigante,
nell'ultimo secolo e mezzo.
Però, non per tutti:
non è arrivato a tutti, questo.
Guardate come stanno crescendo
le disuguaglianze, a livello globale,
guardate il numero delle persone -
erano 42 nel 2017,
sono diventate 26 nel 2018,
che possiedono la stessa ricchezza
di tre miliardi e mezzo
delle persone più povere.
Oppure guardate Jeff Bezos,
che da solo ha, come suo patrimonio,
l'equivalente dell'uno percento -
Il budget per la salute dell'Etiopia
è l'uno percento di tutta
la ricchezza di Jeff Bezos.
Basterebbe un gesto di Jeff Bezos
per cambiare completamente
i destini dell'Etiopia.
Ci piace un mondo così? Mica tanto!
Eppure è un mondo che progredisce.
Però progredisce in modo diseguale,
in modo sbilanciato.
E allora noi che siamo evoluzionisti,
dobbiamo sempre analizzare,
quando c'è una tendenza, un trend,
che cosa c'è dentro.
Quindi Pinker ha ragione.
Però questo è un progresso:
innanzitutto, sbilanciato;
è un progresso ambivalente;
ed è un progresso che non è per tutti.
E poi, aggiungerei anche,
è un progresso che ha
degli effetti collaterali.
Ce ne sono tanti:
si parla tanto di climate change,
ovviamente, di crisi ambientale.
Anche qui qualche dato secco,
tanto per farvi capire:
secondo "Nature" e "Science"
che non sono esattamente due riviste
di militanza ecologista radicale,
ma sono le due più importanti
riviste scientifiche al mondo,
ormai Homo Sapiens
ha distrutto, ha fatto fuori -
dipende dai gruppi
che prendete in considerazione -
dal 35 al 40 percento
di tutti gli altri esseri viventi.
Cioè una sola specie, da sola,
ha fatto fuori più di un terzo
di tutte le altre.
Non era mai successo nell'evoluzione.
Ed è una pessima idea
anche da un punto vista evoluzionistico.
Per esempio, se calano gli insetti,
una parte preponderante
delle colture nel mondo
dipendono direttamente o indirettamente
dagli insetti impollinatori.
Stiamo facendo qualcosa che va
anche contro i nostri interessi.
Oppure guardate il tema
delle plastiche e delle microplastiche:
anche all'Università di Padova
ci stiamo lavorando,
stiamo cercando di quantificarle.
Tutti parliamo delle
plastiche macroscopiche,
la famosa isola che c'è nel Pacifico,
migliaia di chilometri
di plastica che galleggia.
Certo, è una cosa orrenda, terribile:
però quella la vediamo, di plastica.
In realtà, quella di cui dobbiamo
preoccuparci di più
è quella che anche noi scienziati
abbiamo sottovalutato troppo a lungo:
sono le microplastiche, piccolissime,
al di sotto di un terzo di millimetro
che stanno impregnando tutti i mari
e tutti gli oceani del mondo.
Il fiume Po, in Italia,
dalla Pianura Padana ne riversa
migliaia di tonnellate, costantemente,
nell'Adriatico.
Hanno impregnato addirittura
gli abissi oceanici, le micro plastiche.
E noi - eppure tre secoli fa
ci siamo dati il nome di "Homo Sapiens":
come diceva Oscar Wilde:
"Mai participio fu dato
in modo così frettoloso".
E certo, era un po' pessimista,
lui, d'accordo:
però provate a pensare
alle micro plastiche:
si infiltrano in tutti gli animali,
in quasi la metà dei cetacei
di tutto il mondo
ci sono micro-plastiche,
e in quasi un terzo dei pesci,
compresi quelli che noi ci mangiamo
e andiamo a comprare al mercato.
Quindi noi: gettiamo la spazzatura;
ci laviamo i tessuti sintetici, il pile;
le lavatrici buttano queste fibre
di micro plastica nell'acqua;
e poi ci mangiamo la nostra spazzatura.
Homo Sapiens:
un homo che fa la spazzatura,
la butta in mare e poi se la mangia.
Pensate che la Ellen McArthur Foundation,
che è la più importante
fondazione internazionale
che finanzia ricerche sulla plastica,
ha fatto un calcolo
che io continuo adesso a non crederci;
ma andate a guardare il calcolo
che hanno fatto: non fa una piega.
Se andiamo avanti così,
e di anno in anno
continuiamo a pescare pesce
come stiamo facendo adesso,
in modo indiscriminato
in molte parti del mondo,
e in compenso buttiamo dentro
plastica e micro-plastica,
entro il 2050, come massa,
ci sarà più plastica che pesce
nei mari della Terra.
Più plastica che pesci
nei mari della Terra!
Nel 2050.
Homo sapiens. Ok?
C'è un problema, evidentemente, qua,
che dobbiamo considerare.
Ora noi siamo evoluzionisti
e lo consideriamo così,
senza mai darne una valutazione etica
ma quantomeno, inizialmente,
una valutazione tecnica, scientifica.
Che cosa sta succedendo?
Sta succedendo quello che noi umani
facciamo da tanto tempo,
e che ha decretato il nostro successo,
non c'è alcun dubbio.
Come ho detto una volta
un grande evoluzionista, Richard Lewontin,
noi siamo quelli che hanno smesso
di adattarsi all'ambiente,
rincorrendo i cambiamenti ambientali;
noi abbiamo inventato un'altra strategia
straordinaria, potentissima,
che è quella di cambiare noi l'ambiente
in modo da renderlo
più congeniale alle nostre esigenze.
Noi siamo i costruttori
della nostra nicchia ecologica,
e questo ci ha dato un grande successo,
una grandissima fortuna.
Adesso però c'è un problema,
e cominciamo ad accorgercene.
Ed è un'altra di quelle insidie
che stanno dentro
il concetto di progresso.
Che ripeto, io non metto in discussione:
ci credo, sono ottimista come voi.
Ma dentro quel concetto di progresso
bisogna essere un po' attenti:
bisogna relativizzarlo,
dargli un contesto.
Cosa sta succedendo
con il "Climate Change"
e tutti gli esempi che conoscete bene?
Sta succedendo che adesso noi dobbiamo -
anzi, scusate: i miei figli,
e i miei nipoti,
dovranno adattarsi
ai cambiamenti ambientali
che io ho introdotto
nella mia generazione.
Avete visto, nei dibattiti
internazionali sul clima?
Una volta, la parola chiave
era mitigazione, giusto?
Cioè, eravamo ottimisti:
mitighiamo, rallentiamo,
creiamo un sollievo
a questo riscaldamento climatico.
Adesso sono diventate due,
le parole d'ordine fondamentali:
mitigazione e adattamento.
Cioè, ormai è già successo.
Dobbiamo adattarci,
dobbiamo farcene una ragione,
dobbiamo cercare di vivere
in un mondo che cambierà
a causa della nostra
costruzione di nicchia.
Lo fanno anche altre specie:
lo fanno anche i castori.
Questa è una bellissima diga di castori.
Il castoro cosa fa? Fa la stessa cosa:
costruisce un artefatto molto bello
che è funzionale per lui,
per la sua riproduzione
e per la sua sopravvivenza
e così facendo cambia il mondo.
Perché, per esempio, crea un lago,
crea acqua ferma stagnante
che diventa un ambiente per altre specie.
Cambia il mondo, lo cambia
per renderlo più consono a lui.
Ecco: noi siamo castori
andati un po' fuori controllo.
Noi siamo dei castori che si sono fatti
un po' prendere la mano, diciamo.
E quindi, il Climate Change
per noi evoluzionisti che cos'è?
È un grande esperimento evolutivo.
So che può sembrare cinico, ma è così:
è un grande esperimento evolutivo
su larga scala, globale,
che sta cambiando il mondo.
Favorirà qualche specie,
e invece sarà a sfavore
di molte altre specie
che già adesso si stanno estinguendo
a causa del cambiamento climatico.
Ma noi, noi possiamo
salvare davvero il pianeta?
Il pianeta si salva da solo, ovviamente.
Noi che cosa possiamo capire qua,
se siamo lungimiranti
e se siamo intelligenti?
Che questo pianeta lo stiamo cambiando
in modo talmente veloce,
talmente rapido e talmente miope
che rischiamo di pagarne
caramente le conseguenze.
Rischiamo di pagarle care:
se gli ecosistemi non sono più
così generosi con noi
in termini di fertilità - avete presente?
Desertificazione, tutti i problemi
connessi al Climate Change;
e in termini di ciclo
dell'acqua e così via -
Noi dovremo pagare
quei servizi ecosistemici,
che diventeranno più rari.
Gli economisti sanno
che quando qualcosa
diventa rara, la devi pagare;
quindi potrebbe essere quella
che viene chiamata una trappola evolutiva.
C'è qualche elemento di speranza?
Sì, in realtà: perché vedete,
questo schema è un po' astratto
per dire la stessa cosa.
Noi cambiamo il mondo
e dobbiamo adattarci ai cambiamenti
che noi stessi abbiamo introdotto.
E quindi cosa vuol dire?
Che quando io ho dei figli -
io ne ho tre che hanno pressappoco
l'età di Greta Thumberg, o poco meno -
che cosa sto passando ai miei figli?
Sto passando i miei geni,
e quelli li ho già passati, insieme
con quelli di mia moglie, naturalmente;
gli passo delle idee,
gli passo la cultura,
gli passo le mie invenzioni,
quindi la trasmissione culturale;
ma gli sto passando
anche i cambiamenti ambientali,
che io ho introdotto nella mia generazione
e che loro si ritrovano.
Loro sono i nativi climatici,
quindi i nativi climatici, io spero,
avranno anche una mentalità diversa,
e un'inventiva diversa,
per poter venirne fuori,
perché ci sono nati dentro.
Ma questa è solo una speranza.
Ripeto: da evoluzionista,
è sempre bene ricordare
che questa è una vecchia storia.
Noi siamo una specie molto giovane,
abbiamo soltanto 200.000 anni,
e ce li siamo giocati abbastanza bene,
è stata una tumultuosa,
meravigliosa evoluzione,
Abbiamo soltanto duecento millenni,
ci sono state soltanto, finora,
8.000 generazioni umane e basta.
Io, nella mia storia evolutiva,
se vado indietro, ho 4.000 nonni e basta,
poi è finita la storia umana.
Quindi siamo una specie giovanissima,
ma anche molto ambivalente.
Vi faccio un esempio:
questa è la mappa
delle grandi migrazioni umane.
Noi siamo una specie giovane, africana,
uscita dall'Africa più volte,
l'ultima volta 60.000 anni fa.
Tutti noi siamo discendenti
da un piccolo gruppo di africani,
circa 60-70.000 persone.
Tutti noi, sette miliardi e mezzo,
che sono usciti dall'Africa
quella volta lì.
Quando sono usciti dall'Africa,
cosa hanno fatto
i nostri pionieri antenati?
Hanno fatto cose meravigliose, bellissime.
Noi oggi abbiamo scoperto
che le pitture rupestri
non sono nate in Europa,
ma sono state fatte prima:
queste vengono da Sulawesi, in Indonesia.
Vuol dire che già
questi primi migranti pionieri,
che hanno fondato la specie umana,
erano capaci di queste cose meravigliose;
ma nello stesso tempo,
gli stessi gruppi potevano vivere
non soltanto ai tropici, all'Equatore,
ma guardate: questo è un mammut
che è stato cacciato nell'Artico,
a 22 gradi sottozero,
in un'epoca antichissima, 45.000 anni fa:
i cacciatori africani -
questi erano di colore,
immaginatevi dei Masai di oggi -
vivevano a 20 gradi sottozero
e cacciavano i mammut.
Chi diavolo glielo faceva fare?
L'unica specie al mondo
capace di fare queste cose siamo noi.
Nessun altro animale
vivrebbe in Africa,
poi parte e va a vivere
a 20 gradi sottozero,
mangiando mammut.
C'è qualcosa di profondamente radicato
nella natura umana,
in questa ambivalenza, no?
Siamo molto creativi e molto distruttivi:
facciamo quella cosa
che avete visto prima,
arte rupestre meravigliosa,
ma siamo anche capaci di grandi capacità
di coordinamento e di organizzazione,
per cacciare i mammut.
E quindi è una grande domanda
che resta ancora aperta.
Vedete, questo è il cespuglio
dell'evoluzione umana.
Guardate quante specie umane
ci sono state sulla Terra: tantissime.
Noi siamo l'ultimo ramoscello là in alto,
e siamo rimasti da soli
perché abbiamo contribuito all'estinzione
di tutte le altre specie umane.
Questo non è tanto progresso,
eliminare tutti quelli
che ti assomigliano.
Però noi siamo anche questa cosa qua,
siamo una specie ambivalente.
Io qualche anno fa, per scherzo,
a un congresso internazionale
ho proposto, a Lisbona -
ma giuro, scherzavo.
Ho detto: scusate,
voi che vi occupate di conservazione
avete detto che ci sono
le specie in via di estinzione
e le specie minacciate.
Introduciamo un'altra categoria:
le specie "self-endangered",
quelle che si sono messe nei guai da sole
o che rischiano di mettersi
nei guai da sole.
E ci sono due candidati:
Homo sapiens, per le ragioni
che vi ho detto;
e poi c'è l'alce irlandese,
che è il megalocero,
che non era un alce e non era irlandese,
ma adesso non posso farla lunga,
che ha contribuito alla sua estinzione
con queste corna eccessive.
Solo che c'è una differenza:
l'alce irlandese non si è accorta
che si stava estinguendo;
noi invece abbiamo tutti gli strumenti
per accorgerci che possiamo
esserci infilati
in una trappola evolutiva,
e che quindi sarebbe bene
uscirne il prima possibile.
E adesso, il che è preoccupante,
stanno discutendo se davvero
introdurre questa categoria.
Ma io stavo scherzando.
E invece, evidentemente,
bisogna essere preoccupati.
Quindi io sono molto d'accordo con voi:
il 60 percento di ottimisti,
30 percento di incerti,
otto percento di pessimisti.
Bene, dobbiamo essere ottimisti,
citando Andrea Camilleri,
però con "beneficio di inventario",
per cui capisco anche
il 30 percento degli incerti.
E quindi sono molto d'accordo
con l'esito della vostra votazione,
e vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)